my name is Alfonso Rodriguez also known
as misty and I play support for g3
sports
I will knew I should be good at whatever
game I played so I just wanted to become
pro at the next upcoming eSport and I
think I started like officially started
probably when like towards the end of
season two took me like its antsy season
3 is when I became a problem but look at
that lemondogs Forrester earlier as they
lose Dexter R&A got popped in the air
Mickey manages to pick up that kill
lemondogs was a turning point for me
because I was actually now playing
against all the people that I either
idolized for a whole year and it was fun
I learned like I learned a lot I I was
really like pressuring myself to be good
and always perform well I got two worlds
and I realized I actually got different
the first time I like like smashed into
a wall I was like [ __ ] bad you know
and that was kind of like what I was
looking for and searching for when I
smashed into that wall at Worlds I
really got a lot of motivation and I was
like oh my god like I can be so much
better
then I have my timeout for toxicity and
everything but during all that time I
was actually like improving myself as a
player I think I learned a lot even
though I was in Challenger scene and I
got a lot out of it so I knew especially
on my time out I also had a time to
think and I think I coached well if like
two weeks or something
it wasn't until I joined origin where I
finally I would say match the players
that were not really P gold or biased or
like narrow-minded and actually just
made me open my mind to different ways
of looking at the game especially
amazing he would always like say
something that I wouldn't really
understand after I looked back at it for
a few times and look at it closely it
made sense to me and you make me improve
as like as a player
everyone had their way of talking to
everyone else everyone had their own
personalities everyone had like their
small roles in the within the team and
no one really liked try to do more than
their roles because everyone was like
stuck in the same way of viewing the
game and same way of playing it I felt
that even if I join the Challenger team
I would improve more as a player than if
I save energy we just didn't have the
probably coaching staff I can blame it
on that kind of like help us like view
things differently talk to each other in
a different way and just open our minds
to different situations
I had to make a decision it was not easy
and I stated some of the reasons why I
made that decision in like a public
Facebook post before I made the decision
I already accepted what the consequences
of that decision would be
apart from the whole winning stuff it
was the only thing that really could
take us both and was willing to like
invest on taking us both so that's kind
of how it went yeah I wanted to play
with friends I want to play with me and
like there was never really a downhill
slope with him so I didn't really see
why I wouldn't keep playing with him if
I would just like be constantly learning
like I had been for a whole year and a
half before that I thought it was a safe
bet to join t2 because four out of five
players were already gonna a clique for
sure and and then there was key keys and
expect I would say that was our
challenge for this split was getting a
sport who can actually expect on the ski
Keys spend a bit painful wait - Sean he
might fight will it be enough
United is gonna finish the channel
everyone say now oh my god things are
really going good you know we're first
time things are great everywhere
everyone is working hard we don't have
issues that there's gonna be a time
where we're gonna have issues because
that's just how it works and it's about
how we like confront those issues and
work towards them and not unlike stay as
a group and just understand them things
can go wrong in at some point but right
now if things are going great so I'm in
a very happy situation
it was just a dream coming true it
wasn't really something I expected this
year I'd say I released the goal would
be to like try to make it other groups
but I think that if we take this whole
going to world sting and treat it as
like an experience and just make our
goal like maybe making it other groups
maybe not just agree with OG but really
like trying to learn as much as we can
from this experience I think we can
really put up very very good performance